.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Katar -
Austragungsort der Fussball-WM.
Auch Schweizerinnen und Schweizer
tragen im reichen Wüstenstaat
zum reibungslosen Ablauf
des umstrittenen Turniers bei.
Einige von ihnen
leben schon lange hier.
Rund eine Flugstunde entfernt: Dubai,
offener und schillernder als Katar.
Ein Paradies für Fremde -
wenn man sich an die Regeln hält.
Wir begleiten
fünf Schweizerinnen und Schweizer,
die sich auf das Abenteuer
am Golf eingelassen haben.
Worin liegt der Reiz? Was sind
die Herausforderungen des Alltags?
Fühlen sie sich trotz
des Kulturunterschieds heimisch?
Es ist August in Doha,
der Hauptstadt Katars.
Chris Franzen muss noch einiges
von seiner To-do-Liste streichen,
bevor er sein Hotel eröffnen kann.
Bereits vor ein paar Monaten
bestellte der Zermatter
für seine VIP-Gäste
eine exklusive Mitfahrgelegenheit.
Doch noch parkt sie im Showroom.
Good to see you!
- How are you?
All good?
- Good.
Das ist ein teures Auto.
Es kostet 3 Mio. Katari-Rial.
Und die Versicherung ist auch teuer.
Sie kostet etwa 2,2 %,
das entspricht ungefähr 13'000 Fr.
Darum bringt es nichts,
wenn man ihn zu früh registriert.
Wir werden ihn
demnächst registrieren.
Und dann fährt er zum Hotel,
für unsere Gäste zum Mitfahren.
Für umgerechnet 800'000 Fr.
bekommt Chris die britische Legende.
Was natürlich ganz schön ist,
gerade in der Hitze hier ...
Et voilà! Ein schöner Regenschirm.
Oder Sonnenschirm in dem Fall.
Mindestens so legendär:
die Kühlerfigur,
die Spirit of Ecstasy.
Ein begehrtes Diebstahlobjekt.
Gone.
Der Luxus hier
ist schon ganz anders als in Europa.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen:
Luxushotellerie -
das waren Hoteliers aus der Schweiz,
Deutschland und Österreich,
die Luxus kreierten,
die den Gast verstanden.
Und das dann in die grosse,
weite Welt hinaustrugen.
Ich würde eher sagen,
dass ich ein Ambassador of Luxus bin
als ein Geniesser von Luxus,
der sich das selbst leisten kann.
In Katar gibt es zwei Jahreszeiten:
Sommer und Winter.
Dass die Fussball-WM im November
stattfindet, hat einen Grund:
In den Sommermonaten
ist das Wüstenklima so extrem,
dass man sich eigentlich nur in
klimatisierten Räumen aufhalten kann.
Auch Coralie kommt mit ihren Kindern
oft hierher, weil es erträglich ist.
Im Sommer bleibt man eher drinnen,
weil es sehr heiss ist.
Die Luftfeuchtigkeit ist zu hoch.
V.a. für die Kinder.
Selbst hier drinnen schwitze ich.
Kaum vorstellbar,
wie es gerade draussen wäre.
* Abdulrahman kreischt. *
Das hier machen wir normalerweise
entweder freitags oder samstags.
Dann gehen wir nach Hause.
Die Kinder sind müde. Wir sind müde.
Wir schlafen
danach alle ziemlich gut.
* Sie sprechen arabisch. *
* Abdulrahman kreischt. *
Heute
ist ausnahmsweise auch Saeed dabei.
Der zweijährige Abdulrahman
wächst in einem anderen Katar auf
als seine Eltern.
Als Coralie und Saeed Kinder waren,
erstreckte sich hier noch die Wüste.
Ich finde es cool!
Mein Sohn ist ein bisschen
zu klein für einige Spiele hier.
In ein paar Jahren
ist es sicher besser.
Coralie hat sich mit ihrem Cousin
Viren zum Lunch verabredet.
Viren ist auch in Doha aufgewachsen
und hat ihre Beziehung
zu Saeed von Beginn an miterlebt.
Saeed ist wegen seines Motorradsports
oft in Europa.
Coralie wurde in Katar sozialisiert.
Beide kennen
die Kultur ihres Partners gut.
Meine Frau sieht europäisch aus,
aber sie ist es nicht.
Sie ist eher international,
mit katarischen
und europäischen Eigenschaften.
Um ehrlich zu sein,
finde ich sie aussergewöhnlich.
Ich bin genauso katari,
wie er europäisch ist.
Das Interessante: Es funktioniert -
aber nicht immer.
Wenn er beschliesst,
katari zu sein, ist er katari.
Wenn er beschliesst, europäisch
zu sein, ist er europäisch.
Aber es funktioniert gut.
Sie gehen gemeinsam
durch ihre Höhen und Tiefen.
Und sie kommen
immer als Gewinner heraus.
Sie unterstützen sich gegenseitig -
bei allem, was sie tun,
sei es bei Saeeds Rennsport
oder Coralies Karriere.
Sie unterstützen
die Ziele des anderen.
Und sie arbeiten
als Paar an ihrer Beziehung.
Schön.
Doha durchlebt
aktuell einen gigantischen Wandel,
den die Nachbarmetropole Dubai
längst hinter sich hat.
Nur im alten Stadtkern, der Mitte
des 19. Jh. am Hafen entstand,
ist das Dubai
von damals noch spürbar.
Und die Zeichen
stehen weiter auf Wachstum.
Matteo Boffa ist mit Ehefrau Megan
unterwegs zu einer neu gebauten
Siedlung ausserhalb des Zentrums.
Die beiden
wollen eine Familie gründen.
Dazu gehören Haus und Garten.
Regelmässig schauen sie sich um,
was der Immobilienmarkt so hergibt.
Dieses kleine Reihenhaus
kostet umgerechnet 450'000 Fr.
Here we are at the Villanova
by Dubai Properties.
Im Moment leben Matteo und Megan
in ihrem trendigen Appartement.
Der Umzug in
eine solche Einfamilienhaussiedlung
wäre eine grosse Veränderung.
Jede Community hier, die es gibt,
kommt mit einem eigenen Pool,
einem eigenen Gym, mit Sportplätzen,
wie Tennis, Fussball, Basketball.
Das ist alles
in der Community inkludiert.
Das Konzept ist darauf ausgelegt,
dass die Leute die Community
nicht mehr verlassen müssen,
wenn sie hier leben.
Wie so oft ein Knackpunkt:
die Grösse.
Matteo und Megan versprechen sich
vom Hauskauf v.a. eines: mehr Platz.
Und auch einen hübschen Garten.
Okay.
Der Aussenbereich ist superwichtig -
für die Katzen,
damit sie so viel draussen
sein können, wie sie möchten.
Und natürlich,
wenn wir Kinder haben.
Sie brauchen draussen Platz,
um herumzulaufen.
Wir wollen uns nicht verschlechtern.
Der Aussenbereich
sollte grösser sein.
Grosszügig
und mit viel Wasser begrünt
ist der 119 ha
grosse Dubai Safari Park.
Andreas Vater
ist aus der Schweiz angereist.
Es sind Ferien in Dubai: Eine gute
Gelegenheit, um mit Enkelin Sophie
ein paar der 3'000 Tierarten hier
zu bewundern.
Schau, da haben sie Bäume gemacht,
wie Affenbrotbäume.
Ja.
Die heissen Affenbrotbäume
in Afrika.
Ja, das ist schon ...
Dubai hat immer das grösste.
Ich muss etwas trinken.
Ich verstecke mich schnell.
Der Ramadan ...
Schnell verstecken.
Aktuell haben wir hier ja Ramadan.
Da sollte man in der Öffentlichkeit
nicht trinken und essen.
Aber Kinder dürfen zum Glück.
Die Aussentemperatur
beträgt um die 40 °C.
Das ist nicht nur
für die Zoobesucher anstrengend.
Doch weil Dubai
weder Kosten noch Mühen scheut,
findet sich auch dafür eine Lösung:
eine Outdoor-Klimaanlage
für Mensch und Tier.
Das sind die Geräusche der Wildnis:
Ventilatoren.
Das ist schon etwas Spezielles,
Ventilatoren mit Wasser.
Ja.
In der grössten Hitze
bekommst du eine Abkühlung.
Das hier ist eine andere Welt.
Energetisch sicher
mit dem Strom von den Solarpanels.
Aber es ist schön, muss ich sagen.
Dann bleiben wir einfach hier,
oder was?
Für Andreas Vater sind gemeinsame
Erlebnisse mit Sophie selten.
Doch der Pensionär macht das Beste
daraus und kommt oft hierher.
Er war als Reiseleiter früher oft
in der Welt unterwegs und versteht,
wie bereichernd diese Erfahrung für
seine Tochter und seine Enkelin ist.
Uh!
Man ist einfach privilegiert.
Und ... äh ...
Wir leben in einem Land, in dem
andere eigentlich Urlaub machen.
Ich denke nicht, dass ich diese Zeit
in der Schweiz gehabt hätte,
wie ich sie jetzt hier
mit Sophie verbringen kann.
Daheim
kommt automatisch dieser Druck:
"Ich muss arbeiten,
ich muss, ich muss, ich muss."
Ich hatte immer dieses Gefühl:
"Ich muss, ich muss, ich muss."
Am Anfang hatte ich es hier
sehr stark, dieses Müssen.
Und jetzt kann ich sagen:
"Es ist gut, wenn ich nicht muss."
Für Andrea
ist es ein Abenteuer auf Zeit.
Megan und Matteo wollen länger
bleiben - und suchen ihr Traumhaus.
Der Garten ist hübsch -
und grösser als der andere vorher.
Das zweite Objekt an diesem Tag
scheint etwas vielversprechender.
Es scheint sehr geschützt zu sein.
Man hat seinen privaten Raum.
Und es gibt einen kleinen Rasen.
Ja, es wäre schön, mit einem kleinen
Pool und einer kleinen Schaukel.
Das könnte funktionieren.
Anders als der Neubau
wurde dieses Haus schon bewohnt.
Die Küche ist 15 Jahre alt.
Matteo ist ein guter Unternehmer,
aber handwerklich
nicht sehr talentiert.
Einen zusätzlichen Raum
für die Nanny -
wie es in vielen Familien hier
üblich ist - braucht das Paar nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt
bin ich gegen eine Nanny.
Für uns Schweizer ist es unüblich.
Ich bin ohne Nanny aufgewachsen.
Meine Mutter war allein mit drei
Kindern und hat das toll gemacht.
Also bleibt alles an Megan hängen?
Oder wie genau
hat sich der 31-Jährige
die Kinderbetreuung vorgestellt?
Ich würde gerne zu Hause bleiben
und von zu Hause arbeiten.
Ich mache das ja schon seit vielen
Jahren. Ausserdem koche ich gerne.
Ich glaube,
ich wäre ein guter Vater.
Ob die beiden ihre Kinder
in einem solchen Community-Haus
aufziehen werden,
hängt auch vom Erfolg seiner
nächsten Business-Investitionen ab.
In diesem Preissegment
und in diesen Communitys
sehen die Häuser
natürlich alle gleich aus.
Aber wenn das Geschäft
in Zukunft gut läuft,
kann man auch nach
etwas Aussergewöhnlicherem schauen.
Zurück in Katar.
Für die Familie von Chris
gibt es traurige Neuigkeiten.
Rachel muss überraschend
in ihre Heimat Australien reisen.
Ihr Vater ist schwer krank.
Wer sich
für ein Leben als Expat entscheidet,
opfert damit
immer die Nähe zum Elternhaus.
Eine Tatsache,
mit der man leben lernen muss.
* Ruhige Musik *
This is my dad.
Solche Sachen
sind natürlich schon einschneidend,
wenn etwas zu Hause passiert -
mit den Eltern oder der Familie.
Ähm ...
Aber
man ist sich dessen schon bewusst.
Das ist einfach ein Teil unseres
Lebens, so, wie wir es führen.
Und es ist halt so.
Trotzdem stellt einen die Distanz
bei jedem tragischen Vorfall
immer wieder
aufs Neue vor Entscheidungen.
Und manchmal
bereut man sie im Nachhinein.
Vor vier Jahren starb meine Oma.
Und ich habe es nicht
zur Beerdigung geschafft.
Das war schlimm,
weil wir uns sehr nahestanden.
Aber meine Mutter sagte:
"Sie ist schon gestorben."
"Und ihr habt euch gesehen,
als sie noch gelebt hat."
"Darauf kommt es an."
Deswegen fahre ich jetzt.
Weil mein Vater noch lebt.
Ein Leben, ständig an anderen Orten,
ist auch eine Herausforderung für
die beiden Kinder Alex und Ashley.
Doch für ihre Eltern bedeutet
das Nomadendasein Lebensglück.
Normalerweise zieht es mich
nach zwei, drei Jahren wieder weg.
Dann will ich weiter.
Also für die nächsten paar Jahre
sehe ich nicht,
dass wir für den Rest unseres Lebens
an einem Ort wohnen.
Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen,
an einem Ort zu leben.
Mein Sohn schon.
Diesen Sommer meinte er,
er würde gerne in der Schweiz leben.
Aber Ashley ist eher wie wir.
Oder wie du.
Now, she doesn't have her coat on.
Morgen früh
trifft Rachel ihren Bruder in Sydney.
Über 12'000 km Luftlinie
liegen vor ihr.
Bye.
Im Haus von Coralie
herrscht Aufbruchstimmung.
Yeah. Okay.
Yeah.
Coralie und Saeed haben Geld
für ein eigenes Haus gespart.
Die Genehmigung ist erteilt,
doch noch gibt es offene Punkte -
u.a. die Grösse des Madschlis,
des offiziellen Besuchsraums,
der in katarischen Häusern
für die Männer reserviert ist.
Seit ewigen Zeiten
hat jedes Haus einen Raum,
den wir "Madschlis" nennen.
Die meisten Häuser
haben dafür ein extra Gebäude.
Wenn man herumfährt,
sieht man sie neben den Wohnhäusern,
kleine Bauten mit Lichtern und Autos
davor. Da sitzen die Männer.
Wenn du Freunde zum Lunch einlädst,
kommen sie nicht ins Haus,
sondern gehen in den Madschlis.
Das Haus
hat seine eigene Privatsphäre.
Dieses Haus hat auch zwei Eingänge.
Eine Tür ist hier, die andere dort.
Diesen Bereich dahinter
würde man als Madschlis nutzen,
und dort ist das Haus.
Und diese Seite würde man zumachen.
Dies ist
die Vorderansicht des Hauses.
Das ist die Rückseite.
Es ist ganz anders
als die normalen Häuser hier.
Das gab Probleme,
als wir wegen der Baugenehmigung
zur Regierung gingen.
Eine Wand hat so kleine Vorsprünge.
Es ist ein Design, vielleicht 20 cm.
Sie wollten es gerade.
Aber nein, gerade ist hässlich,
ich möchte es genau so.
Gemeinsam ein Haus zu bauen, ist
eine Challenge für jede Beziehung.
Ein Haus in Katar zu bauen,
bedeutet für Coralie zudem,
dass die Schweiz
ihre Feriendestination bleiben wird.
Ideal wäre,
ich hätte einen Job, bei dem ich ...
Oder nein, wenn ich aufhören könnte
zu arbeiten.
Am ersten Tag der Ferien
ab in die Schweiz,
ins Haus meines Vaters
für den ganzen Sommer
und erst am letzten Tag zurück,
bevor die Schule anfängt.
Am nächsten Morgen in Doha.
Chris erscheint immer
zur selben Zeit am Arbeitsplatz -
wie die meisten seiner Angestellten.
Morning.
Knapp 900 werden es bei der Eröffnung
in acht Wochen sein.
Der Stresspegel steigt, aber
Chris ist solche Situationen gewohnt.
Morning.
Ich glaube schon, dass mein
Führungsstil sehr hands on ist.
Mir ist wichtig, dass sie keine ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Angst ist das falsche Wort.
Dass wirklich alle zu mir
ins Büro kommen können,
wenn sie ein Problem haben.
Man darf nicht vergessen:
Viele der Kollegen
sind zum ersten Mal weg von daheim.
Und das ist natürlich
ein einschneidendes Erlebnis.
Einen dreistelligen Millionenbetrag
investiert der katarische Besitzer
in den Neubau.
Damit bis im November alles klappt,
heisst es jeden Tag:
üben, üben, üben.
Good morning.
Das geht schon los,
wenn du in ein Zimmer reinkommst.
Wie ein Kissen daliegt, dass
kein Reissverschluss zu sehen ist,
dass bei der Lampe
der Saum auf die andere Seite guckt.
Das sind Kleinigkeiten, die
in der Luxushotellerie wichtig sind.
Hier ist die schöne Seesicht.
Du hoffst natürlich,
dass alles fertig wird.
Aber ich bin jetzt ein Jahr hier,
und du siehst schon,
wie schnell es vorwärtsgeht
und wie organisiert sie sind.
Organisation ist das wichtigste Wort
für einen Hotelmanager.
Läuft das kleinste Rad
im Getriebe falsch,
gerät der ganze Betrieb ins Stocken.
Man muss sich vorstellen:
Es gibt 150 verschiedene Rezepte
auf einem Menü -
nur für dieses einzige Restaurant.
Und das muss natürlich
alles am gleichen Ort sein.
Das muss durchorganisiert sein,
militärisch.
Wenn heute jemand arbeitet
und am nächsten Tag nicht da ist,
kann es nicht sein, dass der Nächste
nicht weiss, wo die Sachen sind.
Und das wird in jedem Restaurant
so durchgearbeitet, bis es steht.
Thank you, guys.
Have a nice day. Bye-bye.
In Dubai steht Andrea
ebenfalls vor einer Premiere.
Sie hat ihre Lizenz
als Freelancerin erhalten
und empfängt ihre erste Kundin.
Kerstin
ist ebenfalls aus der Schweiz.
Meine schöne, neue ...
- Oh, cool.
Mein schönes Studio.
- Ja, mega.
Küchenstudio.
So.
Was hast du dir heute vorgestellt?
So in diese Richtung?
- Ja, oder auch so.
Mir gefällt das besser.
Andrea könnte mit ihrer Lizenz
auch Hausbesuche machen.
Doch weil Ferien sind,
hat sie für Kerstin
kurzerhand die Küche
zum Coiffeursalon umfunktioniert.
Man sieht ganz klar:
Ein Friseurstudio zu Hause
ist auch nicht immer von Vorteil.
Entweder ist der Hund in der Küche,
oder die Tochter muss was haben.
Jetzt hat sie ja Ferien.
Ich fühle mich schon entspannter,
wenn sie wieder in der Schule ist.
Ich bin halt einfach
auch noch Mutter und Hausfrau.
Ja,
aber ich finde das auch gemütlich.
Sonst kann ich auch
zu einem normalen Coiffeur gehen.
Ich finde das sympathisch.
Das ist mal was anderes.
Coiffeuse aus Leidenschaft
und erfolgreiche Geschäftsfrau:
Andrea hat ihr Geschäft in Bern
seit der Übernahme
in nur eineinhalb Jahren
in die schwarzen Zahlen geführt.
Typisch Dubai wieder.
Kerstin hat sie hier kennengelernt.
Ich freue mich,
dass sie jetzt ihre Lizenz hat
und ich hoffentlich
meinen Coiffeur gefunden habe.
Ich darf legal arbeiten.
Hier in Dubai -
da machst du nichts illegal.
Das ist jetzt etwas schwieriger.
Hier dürfen wir
nicht allzu breit sein.
So?
- Ja.
Das ist nicht so das Wellness-Ding,
das man gewohnt ist.
Es ist nicht unbequem. Ich möchte
nicht stundenlang sitzen, aber ...
Es ist halt auch noch speziell.
Das würde ich
auch nicht mit allen machen.
Aber Kerstin und ich kennen uns
schon von den Swiss Ladies.
Ich würde schon lieber
zu den Leuten nach Hause gehen.
Das hier ist schon sehr privat.
Andrea hat ihr Ziel erreicht:
Sie kann
endlich wieder selbst Hand anlegen.
Über praktische Dinge
wie eine Preisliste
oder ein Kreditkartenlesegerät
hat sie noch gar nicht nachgedacht.
Ehrlich gesagt
geht es mir überhaupt nicht um Geld,
sondern wirklich
um meine innere Zufriedenheit.
Das ist mehr wert als das Geld.
So, jetzt siehst du es
mit ein bisschen mehr Sonnenlicht.
Sehr schön.
Die Farbe ist sehr schön. Die Locken
auch. Es gefällt mir sehr gut.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich sehe frischer aus als vorher.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Danke.
Kerstin wird wiederkommen.
Dubai ist ein gutes Pflaster,
um Business zu machen.
Matteo hat mit nachhaltigen Start-ups
schon einige Erfolgstreffer gelandet.
Hello, Bird. Chip.
* Pfiff *
Und er hat
das nächste bereits im Visier.
Der Grund,
warum ich entschieden habe,
in dieses neue Business
zu investieren,
ist eng mit diesem wunderschönen
Brief verbunden.
Das Team schreibt:
"We may not be perfect today,
but I'm working hard to be there."
"Wir wissen, dass wir heute
noch nicht perfekt sind,
aber wir arbeiten hart,
um dahin zu kommen."
Einen handgeschriebenen Brief habe
ich seit Langem nicht mehr gesehen.
Er hat mir
ein positives Gefühl vermittelt.
Das war der erste Schritt
in Richtung dieses neuen Abenteuers.
Diesmal geht's um schmutzige Wäsche.
Matteo wurde auf das junge
Reinigungsunternehmen aufmerksam,
weil er den Service selbst nutzte -
und für gut befand.
Er kontaktierte den Besitzer,
war von dessen Konzept überzeugt
und investierte mit zwei weiteren
Partnern 100'000 Dollar.
45'000 neue Geschäftslizenzen
wurden allein im ersten Halbjahr 2022
in Dubai erteilt.
Nicht überall wird schon
so fleissig gearbeitet wie hier.
Ich liebe solche Orte.
Start-ups sind super.
Es ist nicht bloss eine Idee,
sondern etwas,
das man riechen und anfassen kann.
Hier wird gearbeitet.
Das ist der Spirit,
in den ich gerne investiere.
Gerade
kommen die Mittagsbestellungen.
Nicht einmal ein halbes Jahr
ist die Firmengründung her.
Ich investiere auch in dieses
Unternehmen, weil ich glaube,
dass die Mitarbeiter hier
gut behandelt werden.
In dieser Branche
gibt es immer noch einige Firmen,
die
ein bisschen unsauber wirtschaften.
Aber hier verbessern wir
das Leben der Arbeiter
und tun was für die Nachhaltigkeit.
Wir wollen auf Papiertüten umstellen
und ökologische,
organische Waschmittel verwenden.
Firmengründer Savan will Matteos Geld
u.a. in PR-Massnahmen investieren.
Im Gegenzug erhält Matteo
dafür Anteile an seinem Geschäft.
Neue Ideen und neues Geld helfen
meinem Geschäft dabei zu wachsen.
Und da kommt der Investor ins Spiel.
Aus meiner Sicht
ist es nicht so gut,
einen ganzen, kleinen Kuchen zu
besitzen, wenn man auch ein Stück
von einem sehr viel
grösseren Kuchen haben kann.
Besser 10 % von einer Wassermelone
als 50 % von einer Weintraube.
Ganz genau, er sagt es.
In Katar bringt Chris sein Hotel
und die Crew weiter in Form.
Sein griechischer Chefkoch zeigt,
was man sich unter einer
Fünf-Sterne-Küche vorstellen muss.
Es geht darum,
dass man immer den Gast überrascht,
und hier gibt es ein paar Sachen,
die wirklich speziell sind.
Das wird der Renner. Voilà.
Genau. Guten Appetit.
Danke, Chef.
- Thank you very much.
Well done, chef. Thank you.
Das Essen sollte
nicht nur appetitlich aussehen,
sondern auch
mit Stil serviert werden.
Eine Aufgabe, um die sich Restaurant-
chef Deniz Otman persönlich kümmert.
Gut. Wie geht's denn, Deniz?
Alles okay?
Alles hervorragend, danke schön.
- Was machst du heute?
Heute wird ein Rollenspiel gespielt.
Mal ist der Kellner der Gast,
mal ist die Hostess der Bartender.
Das machen wir jetzt,
bis wir aufmachen - jeden Tag.
Und immer mal eine unvorhergesehene
Situation mit reinschmeissen.
Vor einem Jahr hat Chris übernommen.
Wenig Zeit für eine solche Aufgabe.
Du hast natürlich Höhen und Tiefen
in dem Jahr erlebt, das ist klar.
Ein Haufen Arbeit, Bestellungen
und du weisst nicht,
ob das Material zur rechten Zeit
in Katar ankommt oder nicht -
wegen der Global Logistic Challenge
usw.
Aber es hat geklappt,
und wir sind da. Und das wird schon.
Zwischen 280 Fr.
für ein Standardzimmer
und 18'000 Fr. für eine Suite
kostet die Übernachtung hier.
Doch der wahre Luxus
zeigt sich im Drumherum.
Das ist
wie auf dem Theodulgletscher.
So.
Jetzt haben wir hier
Zermatt im Schnee.
Erholung in der Kälte,
bei 40 °C Aussentemperatur.
Energiekrise gibt es hier nicht.
Der Mittlere Osten
ist geprägt von Gegensätzen:
Modernisierung und Tradition, Luxus
und Armut - alles eng nebeneinander.
Auch deswegen schauen viele
kritisch auf diese Region.
Mein Blickwinkel ist wahrscheinlich
anders als derjenige der meisten,
die diesen Blickwinkel haben,
weil ich seit 20 oder fast 22
Jahren im Mittleren Osten bin.
Ich sehe die Presse,
die in der Schweiz oder in Europa
andauernd negativ über den Mittleren
Osten oder Katar berichtet.
Aber ich persönlich
sehe das absolut nicht so.
Die Leute,
die so denken und das unterstützen,
sollten mal nach Katar kommen.
Ich wäre ja auch nicht hier,
wenn das Leben hier schlecht wäre,
wenn es keine Sicherheit gäbe.
Oder wenn es etwas gäbe, das ich
moralisch nicht unterstützen könnte.
Fakt ist: Das Emirat
ist wild entschlossen aufzuholen
und Geld ist genügend vorhanden.
2008 hat die Regierung
eine nationale Vision formuliert
und begonnen, die
komplette Infrastruktur zu erneuern.
Geschätzte 150 Mrd. Fr.
soll Katar so investiert haben.
Und natürlich
dient auch die WM der Imagepflege:
Man will, dass die Welt sieht,
was sich verändert hat.
Ein gewaltiger Wandel,
der sich ganz konkret auf den Alltag
der Menschen hier auswirkt.
Das wird
eine grossartige Zeit, diese WM.
Aber auch anstrengend für uns.
Ich arbeite bei der Polizei,
beim Bombenkommando.
Natürlich werde ich
rund um die Uhr arbeiten.
Sie wird rund um die Uhr arbeiten.
Ich hoffe,
der Rest hat wenigstens Spass.
Ich denke, wenn sich der Hype
um die WM gelegt hat,
können wir schauen,
welche Bereiche
man jetzt vielleicht angeht.
Erst waren es die Baustellen,
jetzt kommt die Hotellerie dran.
Gibt es noch Reformpotenzial?
Ja.
Muss alles jetzt sofort passieren?
Nein.
Wenn man bedenkt, was schon
passiert ist, und wo wir jetzt sind:
Das ist erstaunlich.
Von Beginn an war der Reform-
und Modernisierungsprozess im Land
v.a. für die Einheimischen
ein Balanceakt.
Es heisst, Katar hätte eine Menge
Geld für die WM ausgegeben.
Nein, nicht für die WM. Fürs Land.
Wir wollen
seit Ewigkeiten eine U-Bahn.
Jetzt mit der WM
kriegen wir die U-Bahn. Danke.
Müssen wir uns weiter öffnen?
Ich denke nicht.
Ich möchte nicht,
dass meine Kultur verschwindet.
Und das machen sie hier ganz gut.
Sie versuchen wirklich,
die Kultur und Werte zu bewahren.
Der Wille der Regierung,
die eigene Kultur zu schützen,
zeigt sich auch in der Stadtplanung.
Noch bis vor Kurzem
versorgte das Emirat
die Söhne
der katarischen Stammesfamilien
mit Bauland und günstigen Krediten,
um die Familien zusammen und -
wohl auch -
in ihrem Heimatland zu halten.
Um einen schnellen Weiterverkauf
zu verhindern,
gehen Haus und Hof
aber erst nach 35 Jahren
in den Besitz der Bewohner über.
Das ist das Stück Land,
das die Regierung meinen Brüdern
und mir zugeteilt hat.
Dort lebt mein ältester Bruder.
Er ist der Einzige,
der sein Haus schon gebaut hat.
Das hier
gehört meinem zweitältesten Bruder.
Dann kommt mein Land und dann das
meines vierten Bruders. Vier Brüder.
Dies ist
das neue Al-Sulaiti-Viertel.
Mein Vater
lebt in dem alten Viertel,
aber da war kein Land mehr,
das man den Kindern geben könnte.
Daher
gibt es dieses neue Viertel hier.
Mein Land ist das hier,
gleich hinter dem Haus, 1'150 m2.
Und ja, jetzt,
da die Pläne endlich fertig sind,
will ich so bald wie möglich
anfangen zu bauen.
So yeah. Here we are.
Die Zukunft von Saeed und Coralie
scheint gesichert.
Wie Katar seinen eingeschlagenen Weg
über die WM hinaus weiterverfolgen
wird, darauf darf man gespannt sein.
Die 3-Mio.-Metropole Dubai
wird sich - bei aller Tradition -
auch zukünftig offen
gegenüber partyfreudigen Touristen
und innovativen Start-ups zeigen.
In einer Hotelbar in der City
gönnen sich Matteo
und sein neuer Geschäftspartner Savan
einen Feierabenddrink.
Megan ist bei
allen wichtigen Entscheidungen dabei.
Sie spielt eine wichtige Rolle.
Seit Megan
meine Entscheidungen absegnet -
ich nenne es das "Megan-Siegel" -
lagen wir immer richtig.
Es gab eine Situation,
da hatte ich so ein Bauchgefühl.
Ich sagte zu Matteo, er sei drauf
und dran, einen Fehler zu machen.
Er hat nicht auf mich gehört.
Aber am Ende stimmte mein Gefühl.
Ja,
das war in der Tat ziemlich schlimm.
In dem Fall haben wir Geld verloren.
Es wäre richtig gewesen,
auf ihren Instinkt zu hören.
Seitdem ich das tue,
haben wir Erfolg.
Ich habe sie auch
mit Savan bekannt gemacht.
Sie spielt eine grosse Rolle
im Entscheidungsprozess.
Und ich vertraue jetzt
zu 100 % auf ihr Bauchgefühl.
Es ist ein Lernprozess.
Mal gewinnt man, mal verliert man.
Cheers.
- Cheers.
Abendliche Idylle
auch im Garten von Andrea.
Als sie 2019
Remo nach Dubai begleitete,
erfüllte sich für den Ingenieur
ein grosser Traum.
Andrea selbst brauchte
das klassische Eingewöhnungsjahr.
Heute ist die Familie
nicht nur enger zusammengewachsen,
sondern auch heimisch geworden hier.
Ja, man fühlt sich schon wohl,
man kennt die Umgebung, die Leute.
Es ist auf jeden Fall
ein Gefühl von Heimkommen.
Ja, man fühlt sich
halt schon irgendwie ...
Auch hier schlägt man Wurzeln,
vielleicht nicht so tief, aber ...
Aber ich weiss,
dass es mir schwerfallen wird,
von hier wegzugehen.
Das kann ich schon jetzt sagen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Remos Arbeitsvertrag war ursprünglich
auf drei Jahre befristet.
Um ein Jahr
hat er ihn bereits verlängert.
Den Gedanken, dass er die Zelte
bald wieder abbrechen muss,
verdrängt er meistens erfolgreich.
Im Alltag
hat man das nicht permanent im Kopf.
Es kommt hoch, wenn man wegen
der Schule der Tochter diskutiert.
Verlängert man jetzt noch ein Jahr
in der Schule
oder geht's länger,
spielt die Sprache eine Rolle?
Man richtet sich ein,
dass es für einen stimmt.
Aber man muss sich bewusst sein,
dass es nicht für ewig ist.
Bisher war es immer Andrea, die eher
wieder zurück in die Heimat wollte,
damit Tochter Sophie auch noch
ein paar Jahre ihrer Kindheit
in der Schweiz verbringen
und sie ihren Coiffeurladen in Bern
vor Ort weiterführen kann.
Du hast mir
ein scharfes Messer gegeben.
Doch das Schicksal
hat eine Überraschung parat.
Es gibt was zu feiern.
Mit Wasser.
- Prost.
Ich trinke heute Abend Wasser,
weil wir letztes Wochenende eine
erfreuliche Nachricht erhielten.
Ich bin nochmals schwanger geworden.
Aus welchem Glück auch immer.
Ich dachte zuerst,
es gehe nicht mehr
und war der festen Überzeugung:
"Sophie wird jetzt dann sieben
und es ist Zeit,
nach Hause zu gehen."
Und jetzt, da ich die Neuigkeit
erfahren habe, muss ich sagen:
"Uh, in die Schweiz,
mit einem Baby?"
"Eher weniger."
Andrea hat die angenehmen Seiten
ihres Expat-Lebens
mit einer Nanny schätzen gelernt.
Das setzt Remo mit seinem befristeten
Arbeitsvertrag ein wenig unter Druck.
Ich werde jetzt nicht - nur, weil
ein zweites Kind unterwegs ist -
unbedingt in Dubai bleiben
und meinen Arbeitgeber wechseln.
Also so ist es nicht.
Nein,
aber jetzt wäre es natürlich schön,
wenn wir etwas länger bleiben.
Schauen wir, wie es weitergeht.
Ja. Schlussendlich
ist ja alles Familie, oder?
Und egal,
wohin es die Familie verschlägt:
Das nächste Abenteuer kommt bestimmt.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022